Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Bulur, ich bin die Stabender Ärztin auf der Station und ich würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, alles in Ordnung Frau Doktor.
Ok, zuerst werde ich ein paar Fragen zu ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt ihren aktuellen
Beschwerden übergehen.
Wie heißen Sie dann?
Ich bin Franz Betke.
Franz Betke?
Franz?
Herr?
Herr.
Ich bin Herr.
Franz.
Ok, Herr Betke.
Könnten Sie ihren Fondennachnamen langsam büchen?
Ja, Franz, F-R-A-N-Z.
Z, ok.
Betke B-E-T-H-G-E.
Betke, ok.
Herr Betke, wie heißen Sie?
45, Frau Doktor.
45, ok.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
18. März 1980.
Ok.
Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 78.
1 Meter 78.
Ok, und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich bin über Gewicht, Frau Doktor, 114 Kilo.
114.
Ok, 114.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Frau Graf.
Graf?
Ja.
Mit Ende Doppel F?
Doppel F, ja.
Ok, vielen Dank für diese Informationen, Herr Betke.
Was kann ich Ihnen hervorheben?
Was sind Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich habe Fußschmerzen leider.
Fußschmerzen?
Ja, im linken Fuß habe ich sehr starke Schmerzen.
Könnten Sie, wo genau Ihre Schmerzen?
Könnten Sie...
Ja, besonders im linken Fuß besonders C.
In meinem linken C, ja.
Linken C. Ok.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden, diese Schmerzen?
Ja, seit drei Tagen habe ich Schmerzen, aber seit gestern ist es sehr schlimm geworden.
Gestern Abend habe ich nicht geschlafen und habe zweimal Schmerzmittel eingenommen, aber es hat jedoch nicht geholfen.
Ok, welche Medikamente haben Sie eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe einmal Paracetamol eingenommen, einmal Ibuprofen 800 Milligramm eingenommen, aber ein bisschen Ibuprofen hat mir geholfen, aber das ist jetzt auch sehr schmerzhaft.
Ok.
Und wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala bis ein Fonsen, wobei ein sehr leichte Sein sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, vielleicht jetzt acht oder neun, Frau Doktor, ich kann nicht...
Acht oder neun?
Ja, sehr schmerzhaft.
Ok. Haben Sie heute Morgen ein Schmerzmittel eingenommen?
Ja, habe ich Paracetamol eingenommen.
Ok. Aber ich bemerke, haben Sie einen starken Schmerzen?
Ja, ja, Frau Doktor.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten oder brauchen Sie ein Schmerzmittel sofort?
Ja, ich brauche gerne, Frau Doktor, wenn möglich ist.
Ok, Herr Wettke, ich verstehe. Zuerst werde ich Ihnen einen Zugang legen und ein Schmerzmittel verabreichen.
Ich würde nicht.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien gegen einige Medikamente?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergien gegen Medikamente, ich habe Nussallergien.
Nussallergien. Ok. Dann gebe ich jetzt einen Schmerzmittel.
Ok, Frau Doktor.
Fühlen Sie sich besser? Könnten wir...
Ja, ja, danke.
Herr Wettke, haben Sie einen starken Schmerzen, besonders am Seh? Und haben Sie Fieber auch?
Ja, ich fühle mich fieberig, aber ich habe nicht gemessen.
Ok. Könnten Sie mir etwas sagen, wann oder wie Sie Ihre Schmerzen begonnen haben?
Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen?
Frau Doktor, ich weiß nicht. Letzte Woche hatten wir eine Party. Ich hatte viel Grillparty.
Ich habe viel gegessen und natürlich auch Alkohol getrunken.
Und auch gestern Abend hatten wir mit meiner Familie auch ein großes Abendessen gegessen.
Wir haben Schweinfleisch gegessen und natürlich habe ich drei Fleische Bier getrunken.
Und ja, nach dem Abendessen meine Schmerzen langsam angefangen, aber jetzt sehr schlimm geworden.
In drei Tagen.
Herr Wettke, haben Sie viele Fleische in Ihrem Altar?
Ich habe gerne Fleische.
Ok. Haben Sie bei Ihnen eine Arthritis oder eine Erkrankung?
Vor sieben Jahren hatte ich einige Beschwerden, Frau Doktor.
Aber es wurde nicht diagnostiziert.
Ich habe gewartet und ein paar Medikamente eingenommen.
Ich erinnere mich nicht an welche Medikamente, aber Schmerzmittel hatte ich eingenommen.
Dann sind meine Beschwerden weggegangen.
Aber jetzt leider ist es immer schlimmer geworden.
Ok, ich verstehe Herr Wettke.
Haben Sie einige Begleitssymptome mit diesen Schmerzen?
Ja, alle sind dabei. Mein Fuß ist rot und geschwollen und überwärmt.
Mein Zeh ist besonders. Es ist wie Bohrende Schmerzen.
Ich kann es nicht gut beschreiben, aber es ist sehr stark und wie Klopfen.
Das ist sehr schlimm.
Hammerende oder, ich weiß nicht, aber sehr schlimm.
Ok, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Übigkeit oder Erbrechen?
Ein bisschen habe ich Übigkeit, aber ich habe nicht Erbrochen.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß oder Stahlfrost?
Gestern Abend hatte ich Nachschweiß, aber Stahlfrost hatte ich nicht.
Aber nur gestern Abend hatte ich.
Ok, haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich ab oder so genommen?
Nein, Frau Doktor, ich bin immer übergewicht. Ich bin 114.
Ich bin nicht gut.
Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Schmerzen verschlimmert oder verbessert?
Ich kann nicht bewegen, Frau Doktor. Ich kann nicht laufen.
Ich kann nicht belasten. Es ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Ich lege nur meinen Fuß und muss meinen Leck erholen.
Das ist sehr schlimm geworden.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Haben Sie Hüsten oder Atemnot?
Nein, habe ich nicht, Frau Doktor.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzlagen oder Herzklopfen?
Mein Herz schlägt etwas schneller als mein Herz.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich andere Herzprobleme habe.
Ok.
Sie haben keine Stuhlgang oder Stuhlgangprobleme?
Ich habe manchmal Stoffe, aber 3-2 Mal pro Jahr.
Ok.
Herr Bethke, leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Krankheiten?
Meine Blutfettwerte sind sehr hoch, Frau Doktor.
Ich bin dick, wie Sie wissen.
Mein Blutfett ist sehr hoch. Deswegen nehme ich ein Medikament.
Aber ich erinnere mich nicht an den Namen.
Ich habe auch Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit 5 Jahren.
Beide.
Noch etwas? Haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Ich fühle manchmal Schmerzen im Magen. Deswegen nehme ich manchmal Omeprator.
Ich nehme auch Aspirin.
Mein Hausarzt hat mir empfohlen, eine Aspirin zu nehmen.
Er hat mir gesagt, dass ich Herzkrankungen und Risiken habe.
Deswegen nehme ich Aspirin.
Gegen Bluthochdruck nehme ich ein Tablett, das heißt Norvask.
Welche Dosenkrankungen kennen Sie?
10 mg Norvask.
Omeprator?
Omeprator 20 mg. Aber ab und zu nehme ich.
Norvaks morgens?
Ja, Norvaks morgens und auch Metaprolol nehme ich.
Metaprolol?
Ja. Ich nehme viele verschiedene Medikamente, Frau Doktor.
Seit wann haben Sie Metaprolol?
Seit 10 oder 15 Jahren.
15 Jahre?
Ja, ich nehme regelmäßig.
Mein Hausarzt hat mir empfohlen, eine Aspirin und Norvaks zu nehmen.
Ich nehme regelmäßig.
Ok. Wissen Sie die Dosierung, Frau Doktor?
Ja, ich erinnere mich nicht, Frau Doktor.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Vor 20 Jahren hatte ich einen Motorradunfall.
Deswegen wurde mein Oberschenkel gebrochen.
Dann wurde ich wegen dem Oberschenkelfraktor operiert.
Ein Metallinstrument in meinem Oberschenkel.
Ok. Noch etwas?
Frau Doktor, bitte. Ich habe keine Oberschenkel mehr.
Ok. Ich verstehe. Alles klar.
Und brauchen Sie Herb?
Ja, ich brauche nicht. Ich möchte gesund sein und ich brauche nicht.
Ok. Haben Sie jemals geraucht?
Nein, ich habe niemals geraucht.
Aber Sie trinken schon viel?
Nicht viel, Frau Doktor. Jeden Abend trinke ich 2 oder 3 Flaschen Bier.
Bier ist nicht Alkohol. Richtig, oder?
Ja, aber wie viel trinken Flaschen? 1,5 Liter oder 1 Liter?
1,5 Liter, 2 oder 3 Flaschen Bier trinke ich.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Seit 25 Jahren trinke ich Alkohol.
Aber Bier ist nicht Alkohol, richtig?
Nein, Bier ist nicht Alkohol.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie. Manchmal brauchen wir Alkohol, aber Sie trinken ein bisschen mehr.
Deshalb müssen wir das Gespräch wiederholen.
Ok, Frau Doktor.
Haben Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, niemals.
Ok. Und gibt es in der Familie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, leider ist mein Vater an Darmkrebs gestorben vor 7 Jahren.
Darmkrebs, ok.
Ja, Darmkrebs. Und meine Mutter hat Bluthochdruck und Zuckerkrankheit.
Tipp 1 oder Tipp 2 wissen Sie?
Ich weiß nicht. Sie ist sehr alt, 80 und ich weiß nicht.
Ok. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder und er hat auch Bluthochdruck.
Er leider auch Bluthochdruck.
Ok, Herr Wettke. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Mechaniker, Frau Doktor. Ich habe viel Stress.
Die Arbeitsbedingungen sind sehr schwer, ich kann sagen.
Deswegen habe ich sehr Stress.
Ok. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja. Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, aber mein Sohn leidet an Down-Syndrom.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid.
Haben Sie irgendwelche klinischen Probleme?
Nein, aber es gibt manchmal sehr viele Probleme.
Aber es ist eine schwierige Sache. Ich denke, es ist gesund.
Ok. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Ok. Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein, Frau Doktor.
Herr Wettke, ich habe meine allerwichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen? Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Frau Doktor, ich kann nicht bewegen. Ich bin Mechaniker. Ich muss arbeiten.
Was habe ich? Vermuten Sie? Was muss ich jetzt machen?
Herr Wettke, ich verstehe, Sie möchten wissen, was Sie haben.
Aber Ihre Beschwerden können viele Ursachen haben.
Um eine eindeutige Diagnose zu stellen, müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann werde ich Ihre Beschwerden mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen genauer sagen.
Aber sollten Sie jetzt bei uns noch bleiben.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen und Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde einige Laboruntersuchungen voranlassen.
Dann werde ich zurückkommen und erklären, was Sie haben.
Frau Doktor, vermutlich haben Sie keine Verdachtdiagnose.
Das kann Krebs sein?
Nein. Ich habe eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Aber zuerst möchte ich diese Diagnose bestätigen.
Dann erkläre ich Ihnen, was Sie haben.
Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Krebs ist nicht Krebs.
Bitte denken Sie positiv und ein bisschen Geduld sein.
Ich fühle mich jetzt besser, Frau Doktor.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Doktor, ich glaube, Wichmann ist da.
Ja, ich habe es gesehen.
Hallo, ich bin da.
Ich habe mit Freude zugehört.
Es ist schön, andere in der Position zu sehen.
Wunderbar.
Ich habe eine falsche Zeit, da hast du etwas verpasst.
Sie haben eine schöne Simulation gemacht.
Sehr gut.
Sie waren ein cooler Patient.
Frau Doktor, was habe ich denn?
Böse Patient.
Wir sind höchstens mal ein bisschen doof.
Frau Wichmann, können Sie mich hören?
Die Internet-Verwindung ist schwach.
Jetzt besser.
Ihr habt schon Dr. Puppil angerufen, aber ich konnte nicht erreichen.
Das heißt, wir haben keinen Host.
Ja, genau.
Das schadet ja nichts.
Aber wir sind noch ein bisschen wenig.
Mit neuen Leuten sind wir noch ein bisschen sparsam.
Es ist schon 5 Uhr.
Ist es ein großes Missverständnis?
Ich glaube ja, Frau Wichmann.
Es ist ein Missverständnis.
Aber wieso?
Wir haben doch am Dienstag gesagt, dass wir uns heute wieder sehen.
Wir haben eine andere Simulation heute.
Eine andere Simulation.
Das heißt, Sie wollen weitermachen.
Nein.
Die anderen Leute wissen.
Wann ist die andere Simulation?
Gleichzeitig jetzt?
Ja.
Wir benutzen eine ähnliche Linke.
Aber das ist nicht die ähnliche Gruppe.
Okay, es sind also zwei Gruppen, die jetzt parallel laufen.
Wir haben noch eine dritte Gruppe aufgemacht.
Wer war das eben?
Dr. Ukac?
Der eigentlich heute machen wollte, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Oder?
Ich weiß nicht eigentlich.
Einer war doch gerade da, der gefragt hat.
War das Dr. Ukac?
Frau Wichmann, gibt es eine Großgruppe?
Das ist eine kleine Gruppe.
Wir machen jeden Tag.
Aber es gibt ein Problem, denke ich.
Sie müssen jetzt sagen, ob Sie machen wollen oder nicht.
Wenn Sie nicht machen wollen, es ist ein schöner Abend, kann ich auch was anderes tun.
Wenn Sie jetzt Ihre Simulation beenden wollen,
wenn Sie noch Ihr Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch simulieren wollen,
sollten Sie das machen.
Frau Schüle kann das machen, ja.
Und da ist Dr. Ukac wieder.
Dr. Ukac, waren Sie eingeplant für heute für das Gespräch mit mir?
Ich glaube nicht, aber es gibt ein Missverständnis, ich glaube, Frau Wichmann.
Aber Frau Schüle, wenn Sie möchten,
ich glaube, können Sie das andere Gespräch machen, oder?
Dann machen Sie das Arzt-Gespräch und wir können ja überlegen.
Ich kann mich ja in einer halben Stunde wieder melden.
Wenn dann jemand von Ihnen da ist, der noch eine Simulation machen will.
Ich werde die Simulation in der Gruppe schreiben, okay?
Für 20.30 Uhr.
Ja, eine halbe Stunde reicht Ihnen ja, oder, Frau Dr. Schüle?
Ihnen reicht doch eine halbe Stunde jetzt für Ihr Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Ja.
Gut. Und? Ja?
Okay.
Frau Wichmann, haben Sie Zeit für 20.30 Uhr?
Ja, habe ich ja gerade angeboten, ja. Kann ich machen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, um 30 Uhr, ich glaube, wir können die anderen Leute erreichen und wir finden.
Dann machen wir das so.
Jetzt schreibe ich, ja?
Ich höre da nicht weiter zu, ich spiele nicht Mäuschen.
Ich gehe raus und esse dann erst mein Abendbrot und gucke Nachrichten und dann komme ich um halb neun wieder.
Okay?
Alles klar, ja.
Bis dann.
Okay. Entschuldigung.
Alavi, ich habe mich bei Frau Gehildi angeschaut, aber ich habe nicht getroffen.
Arif, hast du eine Extra-Nummer?
Ich habe auch keine.
Dann machen wir das so.